hewlett-packard has announced that its
one-time restructuring more time with
more cost and more layoffs and it could
all help a restructuring cost estimated
3.6 billion dollars in 2012 has
ballooned half a billion dollars more
and 29,000 layoffs but what is
restructuring well first let's take a
look at business as usual let's call it
structuring right structuring has a cost
of building a business you have a new
idea you hire someone to build it maybe
it's awesome but maybe becomes obsolete
maybe it fails so you shut down the
project and you lay off the someone
that's business right
but restructuring when a company
restructures it suggested the shutting
down of the project and the laying off
of the someone is one time in nature
really doesn't count and that's how the
accounting works so check this out
sales go up here cost so that's the
structuring goes right here leaving a
non-gaap profit but the restructuring
restructuring goes down here so that's
the bottom line that's what the
shareholders good but the non-gaap
profit is unaffected the more costs the
company can move from here and down to
here
the bigger the adjusted profit then
there's the bonus question in the last
three years Meg Whitman has received 50
million dollars and Judith Packard a
four million dollar bonus last year and
hewlett-packard has seen 11 quarters of
shrinking sales it seemed net profits
fall losing twelve billion dollars in
the last three fiscal years and
restructuring will cost 50,000 people
their jobs so you'll wonder how did the
companies seeking to cut cost raise
bonuses buried in HP's SEC filings is a
laudatory note a quarter of Whitman's
annual incentive plan is based on
bottom-line financial performance but
the bottom line financial performance is
to find is this now I'm gap profit not
the bottom wine so the more costs meg
whitman can move from here down to here
the bigger the non-gaap profit and the
bigger her bonus and yes the bigger the
layoffs the bigger meg whitman potential
package to be sure there are other
factors that contribute to her overall
pay package and everyone would be better
of HB could ever revive its business but
until that happens
with every restructuring and improves
the structure in the CEOs pay package